120 c'est le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi supplémentaires dans les
ivelines fin février par rapport à
janvier 2013 ce qui porte à 56010
personnes inscrites à Pôle emploi en
catégorie A c'est-à-dire sans aucune
activité dans le département parmi les
plus touchés les seniors plus 15,8 % sur
1 an une donnée qui se traduit sur le
terrain Laurence cousin diveline
infojeunesse était l'invité du 78 ce
mardi elle note que les seiors postulent
de plus en plus à des offres qui ne les
concernent pas
directementcur qu'on peut pas fermer si
vous voulez la diffusion des offres
après ben on les met un petit peu en
garde sur la pertinence en fait du par
exemple du notre site he pour quelqu'un
qui cherchera un emploi à temps plein un
CDI et qui qui recherche qui a une
formation professionnel voyez c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose quant au
demandeur d'emploi de moins de 25 ans il
représente dans les ivelines 8040
personnes soit une baisse de - 2 % sur
un mois une première diminution qui
pourrait s'expliquer par le disp positif
des contrats d'avenir au niveau national
15000 ont été signés depuis sa mise en
place en début d'année par Pôle emploi
et les missions locales alors que le
nombre d'offres d'emplois collecté dans
le département ne s'élevait en février
qu'à